voilà monsieur bonsoir 15h15 cet après
midi porte de clignancourt à paris au
milieu de la circulation
une fusillade éclate une voiture grise
s'immobilise criblé de balles à
l'intérieur tu es net chaque mesrine et
sa compagne grièvement blessé par les
policiers de l'office central de
répression du banditisme qui avait tendu
un véritable guet-apens à celui qui
depuis plus d'un an et demi faisait
courir et narguer toutes les polices de
france avant d'aller plus loin vous
propose de revivre les événements tels
qu'ils se sont déroulés
chronologiquement cet après midi porte
de clignancourt ici au milieu de cette
place de clignancourt chaque mairie n'a
été abattu à 15h ça bmb marron se
faufile dans la circulation
deux camionnettes de déménagement la
bloque à l'avant et à l'arrière
les rafales de mitraillettes part de
l'arrière de la première camionnette
jacques mérine s'écroule mort sur son
volant sans avoir eu le temps de découpe
lier les grenades qui portait sur lui
des inspecteurs se précipitent évacue de
la voiture la pensée de merine
grièvement blessé trois quarts d'heure
après le corps de jacques mary n'est
transporté hors de la bm v nous avons
relevé dix neuf impacts de balles sur le
pare brise la voiture les inspecteurs
qui le suivait depuis plusieurs jours
n'ont rien laissé au hasard
oui rien n'avait été laissé au hasard
cet après-midi tous les grands patrons
de la police était là monsieur ducret
patron de la pj de paris le commissaire
broussard de l'antigang et ils ne
cachaient pas leur satisfaction
y a pas eu de vous soutenir nos
instruments par la preuve
m
j'insiste il y avait des deux services y
avait des deux services au crb et berry
les 19 balles mortelles sont celles de
le crp aussi de répression du banditisme
de la berbie brega l'antigang les
rivalités entre les tenues cet
après-midi oublier au milieu d'une foule
de policiers de journalistes et de
témoins voilà j'ai vu quelqu'un sur le
voulons bien blessé je ne savais pas qui
ce qui s'est passé c'est à ce moment là
que plusieurs voitures civiles s'étant
arrêté son coin c'est cette bmw et
plusieurs jeunes en blouson que je ne
savais pas qui c'était 7 après que je me
suis rendu compte
ils avaient tous des brassards or ce
sens mis par terre parce qu'ils
croyaient peut-être que le blessé allait
avoir des réactions et il se sent vite
levés ils ont entouré la voiture et à ce
moment là c'était plein de voitures de
police étaient prêts mais auparavant il
y avait rien d'anormal y avait juste un
agent de la circulation
césaire le décès de l'ennemi public
numéro 1 est terminée